good way to start a video hi my name is
grace Helbig if you did not know now you
know your life is different now it's
true your life is different now than
when it was before I started saying that
doesn't matter if I'm the reason for it
just life is different you are you know
different time and you were before okay
cool
speaking of time and it's skiing with
all of our brains and the actual idea of
reality and dimensions and that none of
this actually matters it's almost
Halloween Halloween is happening this
Monday don't have to ask Siri about that
anymore
is it monetary what day is Halloween
yeah
Siri she's so needy I've given you a
bunch of Halloween costume ideas already
but I thought why not more because yeah
but this time around I wanted to give
you some ideas for some last-minute easy
celebrity costumes with a twist
so here's it seven or eight or nine six
to nine of them idea-wise
69
you heard that right
69 for our first costume you're going to
need a white button-down shirt no pants
white socks
any short-haired brown wig that you can
find I had this on hand so this was good
enough and then also a cardboard cutout
of a ship and you are Tom Cruise ship
for this next costume you need some sort
of semi modest outfit I suggest some
sort of turtleneck on top and short
shorts on the bottom also if you can
find a short blonde wig that's perfect
but if you can't I just tucked my long
hair into the back of my turtleneck and
made it look like I had short blonde
hair then you want to give yourself a
classic red lip and ski I'm using boughs
from Lilly Singh via Smashbox and you
want to put some heels on really
naturally because this person is very
tall
then grab your statement accessory and
you are Taylor Swiffer Sweeper
I won't lie this next costume is based
off of what I've heard I look like so
you need some sort of form-fitting
outfit blonde hair and heels and you'd
wrap yourself up in any kind of bandages
or band-aids or whatever you can find
the make you look like you just got in
an accident because you are how you
clumsy
for this next one you also need some
sort of tight dumb outfit I'm wearing
this also you need heels I guess then
we're going to part our hair down the
middle and put it in a tight bun in the
back of our head as best as we can do
then we're going to take our final
accessory and we are like we've had
dildo
for this costume we're going to start in
a nude tank top and some men's jeans
then we're going to take a brown wig
this is the only brown wig that I could
get on Amazon Prime now and we're gonna
use it then we're going to cut open the
bottom of two trash bags and tape them
together so they are one long piece of
trash bag that we can wrap around our
bodies then we're going to place
ourselves into our one long cylindrical
trash bag tube we're gonna tuck the top
of our trash bag into our tank top and
then take a shoelace and give ourselves
a cinched waist we're also going to make
sure that there is a long slit in the
side of the trash bags that we are going
on Joely vice
for this next calcium we're going to
keep on that brown wig and we're gonna
add a little sexier of a costume I have
this tuxedo romper dress sort of thing
and then I'm going to add these very
exciting difficult to put on sandals
that I got from H&M awhile ago because
they're sexy and difficult then we're
going to take this cardboard cutout of a
toe I made
put it over our face when we were demi
lovato
I just got some all you need some sort
of sleeveless turquoise bodysuit and
denim pants turquoise pants I'm using
skinny jeans here then you need some
sort of red underwear I'm using my red
bathing suit bottoms to place over my
denim jeans then I actually happen to
purchase recently some clip-in bangs
because I'm fine and everything's okay
then I took a red cape from a superwoman
costume that I had to order off of
Amazon and I tied that around my neck I
taped a piece of paper that spelled out
the word Duff on it to my chest and then
I attached a belt that I made from soda
cans that I covered in red origami paper
that said the word deaf I have glued
them to a piece of fabric and I tied
them around my waist and I became Hilary
Duff man
for our last costume I put the Wrangler
jeans back on and I took a normal white
t-shirt and I cut a V in it then I tied
my hair back so I could put that black
Wonderwoman wig back on but then I tried
to maneuver it into what looks like more
of it male hair style and tied that back
into my hair then I used some black
eyeliner to give myself more masculine
eyebrows and a slightly shadowed face
because of male hair on the face what's
that called five o'clock shadow
AHA yes five o'clock is used for things
other than drinking then I took some
breathe right trips I put one on my nose
and you have it I'm Joe Jonas
so strips
there you go there are some relatively
easy cringing leap any celebrity
Halloween costumes that you can possibly
use for Halloween this year if you want
to let me know if you decide to use any
of those or if you have any other
celebrity pun Halloween costume ideas
because no one hates that in this video
a thumbs up if you like this so I know
and subscribe to this YouTube channel by
clicking this button if you haven't
already because this is not where the
pun stuff thank god it's an unsubscribe
button I don't know
[Music]
that was a good one a minute